Welcome to Thursday
Thank you guys for making it all this way on a
Thursday.
This may or may not be your last session, but
you saved the best for last.
Uh, my name is Steven,
principal architect here at ScaleOps, and
really excited to get through some, uh,
reactive scaling that we've seen
firsthand with many of our customers
and really what we can do to help.
So with that
Some of the things and the topics we're gonna talk about
today is really what is the impossible
triangle and what we're always trying to
solve for.
What are the fundamental
foundations to resource management?
We're also gonna look at
what are the different types of elements that you can size
within those containers.
How you start to overlay things like
horizontal pot auto scaling.
And then once you start introducing
the node layer and how you can adopt
more spot instances.
And then we're gonna get into how you can do this at
scale. This is all gonna involve
custom resources
as well as policies driven based
on those specific workloads needs
or demands,
and then what is the solution look like?
So with that,
What is the impossible triangle that we're all
trying to solve for?
Well, it really boils down to these
three pillars reliability,
performance, and cost.
And within Kubernetes, as you begin to scale,
you're not able to always achieve each
and every one of them.
You end up sacrificing one over
the other. So,
let's take a simple example.
When we start with just 10 pods,
it's very easy to do each and every one of these.
But as you start to scale
to 1000 pods,
you start to introduce more waste
because you're not able to size each and every one of
those applications correctly.
And if we go even further and
start talking about thousands and thousands
of pods,
you now start seeing node fragmentation,
things that are going to cause even more
waste and cause more strain
on hitting each and every one of these pillars.
So
I talked a little bit about how do we
see efficiency today.
Well, one of the major ways
to check for efficiency of the
hardware that you're requesting
is really gonna be request versus
usage.
And as you kind of see in this graphic,
really the developers will
request more than what they need.
But the usage
is much, much lower.
And you may be jumping up and down and saying
I have my nodes fully allocated,
but in reality this phantom waste
begins. So with that,
What is fragmentation and what
do we mean by that?
It really means that as you begin to scale out,
these are conditions that are
used only during consolidation.
But they're not factored in when you're doing
scheduling.
So as you begin to scale out,
there are constraints that will block
these nodes.
So you may have 60%
utilization on many of your nodes,
but at scale 40% is a lot.
So what is the solution today?
There are things like the D-scheduler
that you can use to try to help
address this,
but that is very manual and creates
a lot of
overhead.
So again to kind of recap, this is the dilemma
that we're going to talk about today and we're gonna
dive deep into
what are some of the options that are available today
out of the box
and really what are some of the challenges that those
introduce. So
what are some of the foundational ways that you guys
can manage resources? I'm sure all
of you know here, so I'm gonna breeze through this
request and limits some of the foundational
topics of how you can define your
resources. But
many people don't realize
is requests are just as
important as limits
limits are your boundaries,
but requests is really what the scheduler
is going to use to define
what note it can be placed on.
When you start to see contention
on a node, meaning nodes begin
to become heavily utilized,
is when you'll start to see the
Linux kernel come in and
play a role.
But these all factor into the
eviction logic that we're gonna talk about in
a moment
and that's all around the quality of service.
Quality of service is not
used for scheduling
it's actually used for eviction
when and if there's contention, and
I can tell you at scale there
will be. So what are those is
a quick recap. There's 3
quality of service you have best effort.
This is really when
you've defined no requests and no limits.
You have burstable,
meaning you've defined at least
a request and a limit, but they are
not the same.
And then lastly you have guaranteed
your requests and limits match.
So with that,
what is really the difference between
Kubernetes and Linux and how do those
two play a role?
A lot of people don't realize
requests within Kubernete's is
Mil of course.
But
Linux operating system
doesn't necessarily use cores.
It uses time.
And this is one of the biggest uh
complications for many organizations
is
you can't just look at everything
in just resources on
what the node is reporting.
There are runtime.
Constraints such as
this time you are allotted amount
of time that the CPU
will run your task thread or
process. So those are
typically called time slices,
and today the default
is 100 milliseconds.
So when workloads with larger
requests.
They will be allocated
more time of that CPU.
Think of it as proportional.
And really this only matters when you start to
face contention.
So when a note is heavily allocated.
Then the time will be allotted
more to the one the workload
with the higher request,
and this is what the challenge becomes at scale
is now you're not only
ensuring that the requests are set correctly
but also your limits.
So as I kinda mentioned,
there are C groups, these are
what really enforce these boundaries
that are defined within the pod spec.
And depending on if you're using C Group V1
or V2,
you will see there will be shares and
weights
or periods and or quotas.
Uh, I'm not gonna dive too deep on them, but these
are what the Linux kernel is
going to use
when monitoring each and every process
of that container.
So we talked a little bit about
Kubernetes
versus the Linux operating system
and the kernel.
How does the scheduler all play with this?
Well, the s the scheduler is really
important for placing the pods
on the nodes that have that capacity,
but it has no
concept of this time
that's really gonna be managed by the Kublet
that is running on each of those nodes.
So we talked a little bit
about pod preemption
priorities and
quality of service.
Let's put all these together
to understand what they introduce.
First, the scheduler if you're using
a priority class a priority class
is gonna really help
decide which pod should be placed first.
But when we think of that in terms
of evictions,
it's actually
not responsible for using
anything with the quality of service it's actually
looking for workloads that have
a lower priority
to evict it and that's being done by the scheduler.
On the other hand,
the klet is what's actually going to be
enforcing that quality of service.
So again, only if there's node
pressure or contention,
whether that's CPU memory, GPU,
you name it,
that is when that quality of service comes into play.
It's going to
go through an eviction
logic that's going to decide
what should be evicted first.
So as you saw earlier when it was a guaranteed,
those are going to be the last to be
evicted in the event there's stress.
All of these are again to highlight the
challenges that are introduced when you have
scale
and many, many different developers defining different
needs
knowingly or unknowingly.
So just to recap,
priority class is when
a pod is going to be scheduled,
whereas quality of service is
gonna say which pod is going to
be evicted should there be contention.
So let's give a quick example,
try to put all of this
into practice.
I have a note here that has 4
cores. And
at the moment
let's say in this fictitious node
I have exactly 4 pods
and each pod is requesting
1 chord.
And each of these has
an ability to consume
4 threads.
Well, I'm gonna go ahead and do my load
testing like any
good person should be doing
and what ends up happening
is I go ahead and run that load test and
one of those cores becomes busy.
The other three pods
are idle.
Nothing's happening.
Everybody thinks, OK, we're good.
What people don't realize is
going back to that CPU time.
This one process
because it has multiple threads can actually
consume the full CPU time
up to all four cores.
Now why is that really a problem?
Well,
the problem is you've done your benchmarking
with. The ability
to burst and consume all four.
So you move to production where you don't have
these idle workloads.
So exact same
situation, same exact node, same 4
pods this time,
they're all
busy. You now only
have 25% of that same
time. And
this is the challenge you start to see
app degradation or performance
that is completely different than what you
just did in Dev or QA.
Now,
some people may say, OK,
if I need 4 threads, let's ask for 4 quarters,
but when it's idle,
you're now left with wasted CPU
cycles.
And this is the conundrum and the challenge
that we must face day in and day out when it comes
to Kubernetes.
So that's why it's important to realize that you're
not looking at just
CPU resources in the form
of cores,
but you also have to factor in time.
So to kind of put all of that in
a nice graphic here.
Really we're trying to find that sweet spot.
At what point
is saturation no longer a problem?
So
you find if you were underprovisioned
you have
basically not enough resources to
complete the task and you end up spinning up
maybe more replicas
or more threads
to try to solve it.
When you're at that sweet spot you're able to
finish the tasks
without dropping the packets hitting
that latency or really what I like to
call the saturation threshold.
And this is what you're
always trying to
look for
when you're sizing your applications.
This is before we talk about HPA's
scaling in or out.
This is fundamentally just scaling a single
container.
Without this,
you're just going to exasperate the problem
once you introduce things like an HPA.
So What does
this introduce? Well,
predictability,
consistently.
You're not able to consistently generate
the same performance outputs
when you start to have
these different
environments that have different
CPU time
as well as different usage patterns
across your workloads.
You may think, let's add bigger notes that
will solve the problem, more resources.
Right, just double it.
Well, large nodes do
give you higher percentages in
terms of usable space,
but this leads to overpacking.
And now the saturation is even higher.
So what are some mechanisms that were
introduced to be able to help
solve for this?
Well, one that I talked a little bit
about this earlier,
the de-scheduler.
This is going to help
look for opportunities,
uh, after pods are scheduled
to consolidate them and
reschedule them because today the scheduler
is only
factoring these constraints during initial
creation time.
In Kubernetes 1.33 they've
also introduced in place so if you've made
uh the wrong settings
it's much easier to adjust them
because Kubernetes has now made them mutable
fields
within the pod spec.
And then lastly, if you're using anything like sidecars
and nick containers,
you can now set pod pod
level resources,
meaning that these can be
constraints on the entire pod versus
individual containers within
that pod.
Now all of this has been
focused mainly around CPU and memory.
But what about if we start introducing
extended resources,
something like GPUs.
GPUs today
have some limitations.
Out of the box when you install the GPU driver.
It's gonna tell the node
exactly how many GPU units you
have. But
there are many
other opportunities that we have today
with CPU.
I can
make the CPU fractional.
I can consume and context switch
between that time.
How can I do that
with GPUs?
Well, though it's not out of the
box, there are a few things that you can actually
do and there's a few different approaches.
One is you can install the Nvidia
drivers that allow for time slicing.
However, there are some complexities with this
because it's static.
You set a percentage
for each,
uh, what, what that GPU means to you,
and then you can allot
that fractional unit.
You could also use
the Nvidia MGG,
which is basically a hard petition
of that GPU into a
maximum of 7 units.
Again, this is also very static,
and it is done at the node level.
And then lastly there is Nvidia's
NPS which is
really around using
their CUDA to
dynamically set
what that proportion should be.
All of these have their own pros and cons,
but the key is
this introduces some of the same
benefits that we talked about earlier and how do
you maximize both the resources
and the time
for these
expensive compute units.
So,
with all of that now we have
time to scale this out.
Right, we have 3 major dimensions
that, uh, are really
heavily used today in any large
organization with Kubernetes. You have your vertical
pot auto scaler
changing the size of each and every container.
Your HPA scaling in and out whether
that is with
the V2 or with something like CTA
using events
and then you have your node scaling, the
layer 7 or layer 4 in this case,
to make sure that you're having the exact
number of nodes and the correct size of
nodes. But with all
of that
it's very isolated
we talked a lot about some of these, but
you start off with, OK, I have my
VPA
and then later down the road I
decide it's time to introduce an HPA to scale
out. I introduced my
ID scheduler
and now I wanna start adopting more spot.
Well, all of these are individual components
that
don't really talk to one another.
And they start to
uh overlap and cause
a lot of grief
when trying to achieve those
three pillars mentioned earlier.
So a good working environment
is gonna have all of these
that work with one another.
So some of the challenges with VPA
specifically is it relies on historical
data. It's looking at
trends and patterns
and makes it very hard to react
to specific changes or
bursty dynamic workloads.
You have a peak or a
bunch of traffic that comes in at any given time.
And this VPA is not able to
set those requests correctly.
In turn, you have less CPU
time and now you're hit with latency.
These are all things that you're now trying
to combat
on a 1,000+
environment. So
what are some of the challenges?
Well, Some
applications behave differently.
Maybe I can use my P90.
Should I use a P99?
When should I not use averages at all?
These are all questions that come in time and
time again when trying to decide
how should I do a one size fits
all. Do I have
the same configurations in prod as in
Dev? We just saw an example earlier
that that's not the best idea because
not all of your workloads are running at the same caliber
or
processing the same amount of data.
What if I wanna have specific environments
name spaces for load balancing?
And this really just limits the ability
to have that one size fits all.
So with that
We talked a little bit about one of the new approaches
and 1.34 was,
you know, I don't need to set per container
resources. Why not do a per pod
setting?
Well, today that's not supported
with VPA as as well.
So with all of that
you then start introducing the idea of
custom controllers.
I wanna run my Git lab or
GitHub runners locally.
I want to have airflow, my
Dags, my Jenkins, you name it,
and all of these
are custom top level
controllers. These are controllers that are not
out of the box deployment, staple sets,
stamen sets, you name it,
and these all have their own unique challenges.
How do we group them? Is every
Jenkins job the same?
Is every DA
going to have similar profile or
similar metrics?
The answer is no,
so all of this to say
the performance is really
has not been tested and is not easy
to do in large clusters with many
dynamic workloads.
So let's put those two
topics together.
We talked a little bit about the VPA, but we talked
also a little bit about de-scheduling.
The VPA is gonna go ahead and find an opportunity
to right size one of your workloads.
It goes ahead,
it restarts that pod, assigns the
new value. The team
decides, oh, time to upgrade my image.
I now have a new image version.
And then only after the fact
the thescheduler comes in and decides
to evict it once again
just to solve that refragmentation
or that node fragmentation we talked about earlier.
And you can see the level of interruptions,
disruptions across the environment
when you're talking about thousands and thousands of pods.
So what do you have to do to introduce to
prevent this?
Well, now you're adding more complexity,
time to add PDBs,
time to add annotations
and try to influence
the decisions that these tools are trying to make.
So What are we really
trying to say
is we have to be able to react
to any sudden burst or traffic
to make sure that there's no latency and there's
no packets that are being dropped.
Now it's time to scale it out.
Once you've fully identified
what the resources should be for said workload.
It's now time to scale this out with
HPAs.
And there are a couple different ways you can scale
out with HPAs. You have CPU and
memory are some of the most common,
but you can also use custom metrics.
You can connect through adapters,
and you can also use external metrics.
There's a whole slew of things that give you
real intel
on when your application needs
to meet those demands.
Out of the box it's usually every 15 to 30
seconds
it will calculate what is that threshold.
If you're above the threshold scale out if
you're below the threshold, scale in.
So,
let's take a very simple one.
Let's take CPU.
The Kuble has a sea advisor that
is going to report the usage
of each and every container on said note.
And with that
I can then begin to develop what
should be my scaling thresholds
and what should I do.
However,
out of the box, if you're not changing
any of the caching mechanisms,
it's only gonna last for 60 seconds. This isn't
going to persist. It's not going to store.
Right, this is not Prometheus, this is
just metrics.
So, what ends up happening
is we get into this thrashing loop.
So here's an example. I've set my HPA
to 70%.
Meaning at any time the CPU
goes above 70%, let's
scale out.
Simple enough,
should work great,
right? I'm saving 30%. I'm
saying if it goes above,
it's time to add more replicas
before it is capped.
Well, what we're finding is that
in this example if my usage was
only 0.8.
And I have something like VPA that is
dynamically changing those requests.
When I first started
with that 2 CPU request,
it doesn't scale out.
It's perfectly fine.
But the VPA now decides,
you know, you really don't need that. It's time to drop
that down to one core.
Next thing you know,
my 70% utilization is now 80%
and it scales out.
This is gonna cause potentially going to max replicas
and become counterintuitive with what I was
originally trying to solve,
right? The original purpose was
to solve
the efficiencies.
So, when you change the request,
you don't realize, but you're also changing your triggers.
Even if the load is exactly the
same. So
these have to play nice with one another
and that's where we say
let's go beyond just simply
CPU and memory.
Can we go
and extend this to custom
resources?
So
a popular tool of choice is CA
that's gonna allow you to
scale on
threads or
queue SQS
requests per second, you name it.
So just to summarize, what, what are some of
the challenges and where do we see conflicts?
Well, really
if you're gonna use both VPA and HPA.
Either you're gonna need to
make sure that they're using custom metrics
that is not CPU and memory.
You need to make sure that if you are
going to do it, you do it manually so
that it's safe and meets the actual
demands of your application.
And then also,
you could also just separate them.
Any workload managed with HPA
that is using CPU or memory opt
those out,
whereas those with you can
safely consume VPA
but this does not solve the challenges that we're all
here is at scale.
Now,
great, let's say I do move everything to custom
metrics.
Now the next challenge is
it's still reactive. The fundamental problem
with HPAs.
Is there
going to only react and scale
up when needed?
But if I have patterns and trends,
is there a way to improve that?
Can I limit that thrashing?
And that's where
This is really going to introduce
how can we be more proactive
with our HPAs
and here's a simple kind of timeline to
really show you the problem why so
many individuals are forced
to overprovision
or arbitrarily set their min replicas
very, very high.
Let's say at 9:00 a.m. I have a traffic spike.
My HPA takes 30 seconds before
it finally sees the utilization
has crossed that threshold.
So my HPA scales it
takes me about 30 seconds to download the image,
become healthy,
and it's over 1 minute
before I can even begin handling and servicing
that new traffic.
Hm Hm.
So
Kada will expand what we
can scale,
but it still can't predict
and help us
lower
that lead time
to new pods.
Right, so with that,
this kind of helps illustrate
what we saw when you start to introduce
predictive mechanisms
into your HPA.
Rather than waiting for some
lead amount of time.
And scaling up
being delayed,
you get a lot of up and down unnecessary
thrashing of that HPA and the number
of replicas.
You also have to think of the provisioning of
the underlying infrastructure such as those
nodes. When we're able to
predict those trends in advance
and scale or warm the replicas,
you get a much better outcome,
and it allows your other
investments in VPA and or
node optimization to be much,
much better.
So,
how are we gonna be able to do all of that?
Custom resources is a really
powerful way
to
consume operators
controllers
that can help manage all of this at scale.
So custom resources for those that
may not know are simply an extension
to the Kubernetes API.
They can be versioned
they can be reconciled so that way
things do not drift.
And
more importantly,
it is something that you can repeat across
your various environments.
This is going to also give you the
opportunity to be cluster scoped or name space scoped.
Maybe you have specific clusters that
need a specific set of policies
or definitions
compared to maybe
specific name spaces.
This is really important because
every workload has different characteristics.
Therefore, they all should have their
own custom configuration.
And that's as you can see
JVM
Kafka
all have behaviors
that can't have a one size fits all approach.
So now as we move from
application scaling,
now we have to start overlaying that with
node scaling.
And one of the biggest things that people
look to jump to right away is
how can I consume more spot instances.
And you may say, oh.
Go to carpenter,
flip the switch,
I'm consuming spot.
But what about some of those lift and shift
applications that maybe aren't ready for spot?
Now you're looking to do something like this.
I want some of my nodes to be on spot, some
of my nodes to be on demand.
And though that can be attained
or achieved.
Really that only is governing the
infrastructure layer. How do you make sure
that the apps themselves respect that
same ratio?
For example,
I have 10 replicas.
I want 8 of those replicas to always
be on the spot and 2 of them to always
be on demand.
By just forcing 8 nodes
to be on the spot does not mean
I will actually get that desired ratio.
So what is available today?
Well, within Carpenter,
you can go ahead and define
node selectors that can be used
for topology spread constraints.
This is obviously
going to introduce some complexity
because now on every single one of your workloads
that are maybe you want a fifty-fifty
blend and 80/20 blend
you're adding these
topology spread constraints, the SKUs,
and what you're comfortable with.
And you can imagine the overhead of trying to
implement this to thousands and thousands
of pods within your
environment. So,
what are some of the risks and why do I bring this up?
Well, Pod depletion
or the pool can be depleted of
spot instances. Yes, it can fall back,
but if you have these topology spread constraints
that are hard requirements,
you run into the risk of your workloads
becoming
unschedulable.
Rebalancing today Carpenter
does not support rebalancing
of spot instances out of the box,
meaning as time goes on
you fall into that same node fragmentation
that we talked about earlier.
You can use tools like the
no disruption handler
to try and improve some of this.
But really all of this is gonna
require manual orchestration.
On the development team.
So, what's the ideal world?
Well, the ideal world would be
you define the ratio that makes
sense to improve the adoption of
spot instances
and do it at the pod level.
If you need 80/20,
80% of those replicas
will have the correct affinities to be
assigned appropriately.
So, to kind of
put all this together.
Today there are many, many native tools.
That are available to help solve a lot of these.
But they have to work with one another.
VPA and HPA have many
race conditions if not thought about
carefully.
Your scheduler
today is an append only meaning
I'm going to just add more pods.
It is not interested in looking at can I
go back and look and review
those previous opportunities for better ones.
How do I help with spot management?
Next would be predictive versus
reactive.
Reactive scaling
is really what leads to a lot of these challenges.
Uh, once you introduce predictive scaling,
you're able to ease a lot of
the burdens and inefficiencies
that come
with some of these other approaches.
How do you coordinate across all of these
in a continuous manner?
So That
is where.
We come in
So scaleoffs exists today to
do all of those things that
we just mentioned today.
We're context aware
we're looking at every single layer
of scaling
that you have within your cluster.
And we're gonna make sure that we're auto detecting
the specific workload characteristics to
define the most appropriate policy to
meet the needs of said application.
And then lastly we really wanna make sure
that during any
contention
that there's a way to not only heal
but also react to those sudden bursts
or changes in traffic.
And you don't have to believe me,
believe any of our customers that are running in
full production.
With this at scale.
So to kind of wrap up and
summarize here.
There's a lot more than what I could cover
in this session,
but it's all around how we can
help size each and every
container in each and every one of your
workloads,
how we can influence the scheduler
to place pods more intelligently
and reduce node fragmentation.
How we can help you guys adopt AI
infrastructure whether that's GPUs,
time slicing, etc.
and then what we can do with replica optimization,
introducing predictive mechanisms
so that way you guys can scale
more consistently
and safely.
So I know uh the conference
floor is probably closed,
but if you guys have questions, I'll
be happy to answer
any here. I'll stay for the next
15 minutes to help address
anything that uh you guys might have.
Otherwise,
I, I appreciate you guys taking the time
and coming out all the way over here.